So the benefits and downsides of
bootstrapping versus investing.
In a bootstrapping scenario
you are in control of
what you're able to do right now,
without looking anywhere else.
You can immediately take
action this very second.
You can pause this video and go and
take action if you're bootstrapped.
If you're investing, well, now you
gotta think a little bit more carefully
how you're going to discuss
what your goals and ideas are.
You need to communicate very clearly
what it is you want, what it is you're
doing, and why this person or group of
people should give you money to do it.
On the flip-side,
negative aspects of bootstrapping are,
if you are sitting in a room
that has nothing in it and
your arms are tied behind your back,
your bootstrapping round is over.
[LAUGH] And
there's very little you can actually do.
And if you find yourself in a situation
where there really isn't anything that
you have at your disposal that
can help you bootstrap something,
you're kind of stuck.
And that's where investment
can really be a lifesaver.
Because you can reach out to somebody,
or a group of people for help,
who might have the resources for that
key element you need to do that thing
that will make your business
successful in this space.